[Musique]
je me suis jamais senti aussi proche de
même exactement au même endroit qu'elle
a l'époque terrain
oui je suis en sortir ce soir on fête un
événement important
allez on a une fiesta organisée voyez
qu'ils pouvaient pas venir je suis
quelqu'un de très spontané c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai
[Musique]
vous présente mes pairs il faut bien
trois grands hommes beaux créer une
telle femme
au fait je n'ai jamais demandé comment
vous avez rencontré ma mère
allez je sais pas ce que l'avenir me
réserve
mais le monde est vaste et je peux avoir
de beaux souvenirs
il ya une île kalokairi
d'après la légende si on s'en éloigne en
bateau on arrive au bord du monde et on
tombe
je crois que ces lieux est parfait pour
moi moi c'est bill downe a
c'est littéralement garçon le plus beau
du monde
ex-aequo avec lui mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cette île ça va pas
cet endroit est vraiment incroyable je
trouve qu'on devrait vivre ici tous les
deux que les jours qui nous restent à
vivre sont les meilleurs de nos vies dis
moi tu n'as pas habiter à grand-mère la
pire sorcière de l'ouest
vous avez fric
j'ai décidé de me dévouer à mon rôle de
grand mère grand-mère en tapant invités
c'est le secret d'une fête réussie
monczuk
[Musique]
mon âme soeur je crois que c'est les
graisses en fait
moi ça doit être le fort
on est tous les trois grand père un
point c'est tout
[Musique]
c'est fou ce que tu as fait sept îles
elle voulait que sa mère en soient fiers
c'est bien ce qu'elle a fait
[Musique]
on dit à personne que j'attends un bébé
1 je vais dire bill et je n'ai dit harry
et je les dis a beaucoup beaucoup de
monde
vous allez bientôt devenir
arrière-grand-mère arrière-grand-mère on
va oublier ça dans ma biographie
[Musique]